nice pad richard you haven't changed it  on bruce  you might be surprised  what was that back there a mess it's a  way to keep my lives  separate i can't think of the last time  we saw each other  i bet you can remember the last time the  first time too  i'm eager to learn they all say that ben  turner richard dragon  shiva disciplined honorable  [Music]  she's very dedicated  i assume you're in some kind of trouble  the cobra cult  a worldwide organization of murderous  zealots  kill them we have to stop it no matter  what i ain't ever gonna turn down  whooping somebody's ass  no matter how much you train evil  remains  we're not done yet again  a quarry is a bit more formidable than  we thought  that's handy this isn't gonna be easy  [Music]  remember you are stronger together than  [Music]  apart  you